[Música]
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der layen pronunció su
discurso sobre el estado de la unión y
que dio a conocer sus prioridades
algunas son una unión europea de la
salud más fuerte frente a la pandemia y
la lucha contra el cambio climático
reduciendo las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero
yo si he de suba de 71 años fue elegido
nuevo primer ministro de japón con 314
de los 462 votos emitidos en la cámara
baja del parlamento gobernar hasta
septiembre del año próximo para
completar el mandato de sin suave fuga
fue jefe de gabinete y ministro del
gobierno de su antecesor
más de 1100 en 100 dos incendios
forestales en un mes han devastado la
costa oeste de eeuu las llamas continúan
ardiendo y los estados de california
washington y oregón han sido los más
afectados el gobernador de california
gavin newson aseguró que está haciendo
una situación sin precedentes más de 35
personas han perdido la vida
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se redoblan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo con el discurso del estado
de la unión de la presidenta de la
comisión europea
úrsula von der layen su plan de acción
se centrará entre otros puntos en el de
la salud y el cambio climático von der
layen habló sobre la necesidad de crear
una reserva estratégica para evitar la
dependencia del bloque comunitario de
terceros países en particular en
relación con los medicamentos y propuso
la creación de una nueva agencia para
abordar las amenazas y emergencias
sanitarias también se comprometió a
incrementar el objetivo para reducir las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
elevando lo hasta el 55 por ciento de
aquí hasta 2030 más temprano nuestra
corresponsal en bruselas es ser herrera
nos habló de lo más destacado en este
primer discurso de von der layen
buenos días en efecto ha sido el primer
discurso de la paterna jan como
presidenta de la comisión europea un
discurso muy largo de una hora y media
prácticamente en que como comentabas ha
avanzado esa reducción del 55 por ciento
de emisiones de aquí a 2030 con el
objetivo de que en 2050 europa sea el
primer continente climáticamente neutro
aún así los detalles se los ha reservado
porque será el vicepresidente de la
comisión europea frans timmermans
encargado del pacto verde quien dé todos
los detalles mañana aún así esta
reducción del 55 por ciento es inferior
a lo que pierde a lo que pide la
eurocámara que impide que fuese a más
allá y sea del 60%
aún así von der leyen cree que el 70 por
ciento de los proyectos que recordemos
se deben financiar en el proyecto en el
plan de reconstrucción de la unión
europea deben financiar en proyectos que
vayan en la lucha contra el cambio
climático también ha recordado que la
pandemia no se ha hecho más frágiles por
eso ha avanzado esta construcción de
ésta
parecida a la que ya existe en eeuu para
depender menos de terceros países
especialmente porque medio la pandemia
la unión europea prácticamente no tenía
mascarillas también ha apelado a los
valores fundacionales de la unión
europea ha atacado a polonia con sus
leyes en que excluyen a la comunidad
lgtb y dice que la unión europea se basa
en sus valores fundamentales también ha
avanzado que quiere que haya una nueva
propuesta para la reforma de asilo la
semana que viene presentará una nueva
reforma presta política de asilo para
que se acojan a más refugiados pero eso
sí también quiere que haya un refuerzo
de las fronteras exteriores de la unión
europea finalmente también ha hablado de
política exterior ha hablado de rusia de
su papel problemático en el conflicto en
bielorrusia también sobre eeuu y sobre
china y su problemática relación en
definitiva ha sido un discurso en que ha
tocado muchos temas pero sin apenas
detalles
japón tiene un nuevo primer ministro
yoshihiko es el ex portavoz del gobierno
de xinzo había sido elegido formalmente
primer ministro en la cámara baja del
parlamento este miércoles dos días
después de ganar la carrera por el
liderazgo del partido liberal
democrático gobernante
en el momento de votar los aplausos que
recibió txiki de su gas sonaron la
aprobación por parte de su propio
partido por lo demás no hubo sorpresas
ya que su gas fue elegido el primer
ministro de japón número 99 por una
mayoría abrumadora con el principal
líder de la oposición muy por detrás
este hombre de 71 años es el primer
nuevo mandatario de japón en casi 8 años
aunque pocos esperan algo más que un
simple cambio de cara no creo que las
cosas sean mucho peores ni mucho mejor
es poco cambiará bajo laico espero que
el nuevo gobierno supere la crisis de
coronavirus y celebren los juegos
olímpicos sin grandes cambios en su
política siga dando la carrera por el
liderazgo del partido gobernante con la
promesa de estabilidad y continuidad y
hereda un país en profunda recesión el
pib japón se redujo casi un 8% en el
segundo trimestre en medio de la
pandemia la política monetaria muy
liberal llamada ave no mix no logró
fortalecer la economía en cuanto a la
política exterior se espera que suba
continuo
priorizando la relación de japón con
eeuu
mientras tanto temas como una disputa
territorial con rusia están destinados a
permanecer en un punto muerto
de basic o la política exterior básica
de japón se basará en el fortalecimiento
de la alianza de seguridad entre japón y
eeuu japón no tratará de dañar sus
relaciones con china tanto como pueda
pero no se reunirá de equilibrarse con
china le enseñó alguien saint con
aproximadamente la mitad del gabinete
compuesto por miembros del precedente y
teniendo al hermano menor de ave como
nuevo ministro de defensa el gobierno de
su hogar es visto en gran medida como
una copia de la anterior de jabón vamos
hasta eeuu donde los incendios
forestales en california oregón y
washington dejan a al menos 35 muertos
hasta el momento mientras 97 grandes
incendios en la costa oeste del país se
han consumido casi dos millones de
hectáreas sin embargo este desastre
natural se ha vuelto uno de los centros
de la contienda electoral estadounidense
por un lado el candidato demócrata joe
biden afirma que se deben al
calentamiento global consecuencia y
cambio climático y acusó al presidente
donald trump de no estar al frente de la
situación mientras que donald trump
niega que el cambio climático sea la
causa
juegos al respecto conversamos con
nuestra corresponsal
susana mendoza quien nos comentó sobre
la politización de este desastre
ambiental
los incendios de la costa oeste no sólo
están arrasando cientos de miles de
hectáreas también están polarizando a la
clase de política por ejemplo trampa
segura que estos incendios se deben
principalmente a la mala gestión de las
zonas boscosas mientras que otros
políticos sobre todo de corte liberal
aseguran que estos incendios se deben
principalmente al cambio climático pero
lo cierto por ahora es que hay casi 2
millones de hectáreas que han sido
arrasadas en estos mega incendios en los
estados de oregón california y
washington tan sólo en california hay 29
grandes incendios que arden casi sin
control mientras que en oregón son 5
mega incendios los que carbón ethan el
estado ahora mismo los bomberos miles de
bomberos que están desplegados en estos
tres estados trabajan desesperadamente
por controlar los incendios y también se
puede ver aquí otra otra de las
consecuencias de estos fuegos es
principalmente el denso humo y las
cenizas que hacen el aire casi
irrespirable sobre todo en california
y cambiamos ahora información porque el
colombiano javier ordóñez que murió a
manos de la policía el pasado miércoles
en bogotá fue velado el martes por su
familia y amigos por el dictamen de
medicina legal en la alcaldesa de bogotá
claudia lópez 4 luego su muerte como un
homicidio mientras tanto el gobierno
nacional abrió de nuevo el debate sobre
la reforma estructural a la policía el
informe de amaya
con una ceremonia privada la velación de
javier ordóñez se realizó una semana
después de su muerte el cuerpo del
hombre de 43 años fue entregado el
pasado viernes las exequias se
retrasaron mientras llegaban algunos
familiares que viven en otros países sus
allegados le dieron un último adiós y
aún no entienden la brutalidad de los
dos policías que lo detuvieron en la
madrugada del miércoles 9 de septiembre
en realidad
te esperamos
e
que paguen una justicia como debe ser
solo pues un procedimiento policial de
vino con gas al final
lo mataron
la verdad yo no pude verle el cuerpo yo
solo garcía a ver el rostro
y en puesto el rostro estaba totalmente
golpe a buscar tenía hematomas
en el rostro
el cuerpo de ordóñez presentó
contusiones en la cabeza astillas
fracturadas y el hígado reventado la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez se
refirió a su muerte como un asesinato el
clamor por que haya justicia en este
caso se extendió por todo colombia
decenas de protestas contra la violencia
policial se registraron en varias
ciudades del país en 48 horas los
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y la
policía dejaron 13 muertos y más de 400
heridos ahora en el senado colombiano se
debate una vez más sobre una reforma
estructural a la policía de colombia en
el congreso hay varias propuestas como
cambios en las prácticas de los
oficiales y que el organismo quede a
cargo del ministerio del interior- y no
del de defensa como es actualmente pero
habrá que esperar si se logra una
mayoría para que la discusión empiece
luego de que el presidente colombiano
iván duque se negara a acoger una
propuesta de reformas llame no sé si nos
vamos ahora hasta argentina porque la
lista de empresas que abandona el país
sudamericano no para de crecer
aerolíneas fábricas y grandes almacenes
se suman a una
la tendencia que tiene como razón es la
crisis económica y el coronavirus la
empresa chilena falabella fue la última
en anunciar el cierre de cuatro de sus
locales en argentina en los próximos
meses y la búsqueda de un comprador de
un socio estratégico también que haga
viable la operación de sus tiendas en
ese país para entender un poco más lo
que ocurre con la inversión extranjera
en argentina saludo en este momento a
ramiro marra el ex broker de bolsa y
también analista en finanzas señor marra
gracias por estar con nosotros en
francés 24 y le pregunto por qué
entonces levante argentina estas
empresas extranjeras cuál es la
principal razón me pregunto si a lo
mejor los altos impuestos
bueno gracias por comunicarse la
realidad que la argentina ha quedado en
un contexto muy frágil después de la
pandemia y en consecuencia de la
cuarentena la argentina ya viene de 10
años de una caída de su economía con
altas altas y con altas tasas de
inflación y con como bien plantea bajos
con gran presión tributaria las cuentas
contables se retira no cierran en
términos económicos por más que hayamos
arreglado el tema de nuestra deuda
todavía tenemos cuentas pendientes que
tenemos que resolver para poder fomentar
que las pacientes se inviertan hoy
estamos en un proceso que algunas
empresas verán algunas principales
empresas y muchos comercios tuvieron que
cerrar sus puertas porque el negocio no
es que no les cerraba simplemente en la
cuarentena sino que ya hace varios años
que viene de manera negativa ahora le
pregunto entonces para dónde va el país
se puede recuperar fácilmente o esta
tendencia va a empeorar
bueno nosotros tratamos de ser
optimistas y entender que son todas
partes de ciclos después de un ciclo es
tan malo esperamos pero estamos
esperando que aparezca el ciclo positivo
la verdad que estamos tocando pisos la
economía argentina muy pocas veces
estuvo en esta situación y también en un
momento van a empezar a aparecer las
oportunidades y debes estar contando
porque se van las empresas sino porque
están viniendo estamos en un momento
difícil pero eso no quiere decir que la
argentina tenga que seguir por el mismo
camino en algún momento esto esto va a
cambiar es parte de las consecuencias de
malas gestiones por parte de los
gobiernos sin más de consecuencia de la
cuarentena pero bueno ahora estamos en
búsqueda de soluciones
ramiro gracias a por la información que
tengo usted un feliz resto de día el
presidente de nicaragua daniel ortega
amenazó con cadena perpetua a los
opositores al promover una reforma legal
para castigar a sus adversarios a
quienes señaló de cometer crímenes de
odio las declaraciones de ortega se
produjeron un extenso discurso con
motivo del 199 aniversario de la
independencia y por su parte
eeuu acusó a ortega de recrudecer la
represión en este país centroamericano y
de haber cometido otro y haberse
convertido en otro dictador
el huracán salí de categoría 2 tocó
tierra en la costa del golfo en alabama
en eeuu mientras mientras azota con
lluvias e intensas marejadas según las
autoridades el fenómeno natural podría
causar devastadoras inundaciones de
acuerdo al boletín del centro nacional
de huracanes sal y tiene vientos máximos
sostenidos de 168 kilómetros por hora y
se mueve al noreste el huracán en que se
formó al sur de la florida donde se
produjo intensas lluvias durante el fin
de semana es uno de los cinco ciclones
actualmente activos en el atlántico
el ganador del tour de francia 2019 el
colombiano de gan bernal se retiró esta
mañana de la competición antes de la
etapa 17 que tendrá lugar entre grenoble
y mary belle y es considerada la gran
batalla entre favoritos bernal de 23
años será el favorito pero desde el
comienzo tropezó con rivales más fuertes
que él y con un equipo el jumbo misma de
primos roble hecho más fuerte que el
suyo en líneas
y esta manera entonces llegamos al final
del informativo en france24 continuar
con nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias felicidad para todos
[Música]
la información al momento en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom